normally when you look at a matrix what
you'll see is you'll see like these
brackets right so it'll look more like
this right these little brackets when
you see these bars they look like
absolute value bars that tells you to
take the determinant of the matrix
sometimes you'll see in front of the
matrix Det like that so you they want
you to take the determinant of a matrix
but if you see these bars that also
represents taking the determinant of a
matrix now if it's a 2 by 2 matrix all
you have to do is take this diagonal
multiplied together so you can see I've
represented it as ad minus this diagonal
the one going up to the right BC so
that's for a 2x2 and we'll look at an
example of that
if you have a 3 by 3 matrix okay what
you can do is you can do this method of
minors okay what they call the method of
minors you look at this value a ok and
you cross out that row and column ok so
row and column you cross that out and
what you're left with that square matrix
there you're going to take the
determinant of that matrix and then
multiply it by a ok then when you go to
them this one here you're gonna cross
out this column in row ok and you're
gonna take B times the determinant of
what's left over here plus when you look
at C you're gonna multiply by C by the
determinant of what's left when you
cross out that row and column that C's
in so you'd be left with this square
matrix over here in this corner I'll
show you an example and I'll show you
another way to do it to this may be a
little bit easier so let's get right
into this so to find the determinant of
this matrix here I'm gonna take this
diagonal right here okay
3 times 5 which is 15 minus this
diagonal right here negative 2 times 1
which is negative 2 so that comes out to
17 now sometimes students get a little
bit confused which diagonal you're using
and they get confused a little bit when
you start throwing some negative numbers
in there so I don't want that to happen
to you just go ahead and multiply this
diagonal from the upper left to the
lower right that's 15 minus and then
just go ahead and multiply these
together and then go ahead and combine
those ok so it doesn't hurt to write it
now some students are good at doing in
their head but if there's a lot of
negatives in there you might want to
write it down okay now the next matrix
is a 3 by 3 and what we're going to do
is I'm going to do that method
we're crossing out the column and row
we're gonna work with one here so this
is going to be 1 times the determinant
of so when I cross that wrong column out
we're left with this matrix here which
is 1 3 2 & 4
- I'm going to cross out this row and
column here this is going to be 0 times
ok we're left with negative 2 3 5 & 4
negative 2 3 5 & 4 plus when I work with
this element here 3 I'm going to cross
out this row and column and we're left
with negative 2 1 5 & 2 okay so let's go
ahead and do this so we've got three
determinants we need to take and then we
also have to multiply by these
coefficients here so this is going to be
4 minus 6 okay which is negative 2 times
1 this one is going to come out to
negative 8 minus 15 which is negative 23
okay times 0 and then this one's going
to be negative 4 minus 5 so negative 4
minus 5 which is negative 9 times 3 okay
if we simplify this now we get negative
2 of course 0 times anything is 0 plus
negative 27 so this comes out to
negative 29 now you heard me mention
earlier that there's an easier way to do
this when you have a 3 by 3 matrix and
what you do I'll show you that is you
take this matrix okay let me just
rewrite it 1 0 3 negative 2 1 3 5 2 4
and what you do is you go ahead and copy
that matrix right next to it itself okay
so you're left with 1 is 0 3 okay and
negative 2 1 3 5 2 4 okay so now you're
ready for this little shortcut technique
what you do is you multiply on the
diagonal here okay and multiply on the
diagonal here and you multiply on the
diagonal here
and you add those together so the ones
going from the upper left to the lower
right like that so if we do that we get
1 times 1 times 4 which is 4 okay plus 0
times anything is 0
plus three times negative two is
negative six times two is negative
twelve okay - we're gonna multiply all
the diagonals going from the lower
left-hand corner up to the upper right
so we're going to take this product this
product and this product and we're going
to multiply those together and add so
that's 15 five times one times three
okay
plus two times let's see what's this
this is a three here 2 times 3 is 6
times 1 is 6 and 4 times negative 2
times 0 which is 0
so if we add these together we get
negative 8 minus 21 50 plus 6 is 21 and
we get negative 29 which is the same
thing we got here just another way of
doing it and you'll notice I didn't use
this last column but just for sake of
ease of explaining it you take that
matrix copy it right next to itself take
the diagonals going this way I multiply
them together an add take the diagonals
going up this way multiply together and
add subtract those two quantities and
that's your determinate so I hope you
learned something in this video if you
did subscribe to the channel check out
some of my past videos and continue on
with this matrix series of videos that I
have here for you to learn more about
matrices and I'll see you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon